foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones update
video in this new video I have some very
interesting information that I think a
lot of you will want to hear last night
I was sent an email from someone who
says they work with HBO although they
want me to leave their name Anonymous
they gave me some new information about
the Jon Snow show they have been
developing now based on what this Source
said they know at least one of the main
ideas they have for this show I'm sure
some of you will immediately disregard
this information however I do think a
lot of you will find this to be as
interesting as I did now before I get
into everything there is something else
I have to let all of you know I'd like
to thank the sponsor of today's video
and my favorite game rage Shadow Legends
raid features a massive Universe where
you get to build up your team from over
600 Champions to fight in player vs
player matches or boss battles use my QR
code or the links below to download raid
yourself to your mobile phone or PC my
favorite faction and raid is the High
Elves they have an awesome backstory
their Homeland and aravia has been
around for thousands of years surviving
the fall of lizardmen Empire helped the
humans form into civilizations and
defeated the Orcs when they formed the
huge horde and attacked the continent
but then things got Twisted when syroth
the Lord of Darkness convinced a bunch
of elves to go evil and attack the
kingdom the Civil War nearly ended the
elves but Arabia survived rebuilt and
now it's stronger than ever now this
month is huge for raid they just
released a brand new faction the Sylvan
Watchers was some amazing new champions
forest elves ants Druids Foss they're
all here and I cannot wait to summon
them all to play with and if that's not
enough raid's got a full lineup of
events along with a new season of the
forge pass where you can get your hands
on some of the most powerful gear the
game has ever seen also if you're an
Amazon Prime member you can get your
exclusive rewards and raid right now but
there's even more new players use my
link or scan the QR code on this green
and get a free starter pack worth almost
thirty dollars a free champion Aina and
also this cool in-game loot you will
find your rewards here in your inbox for
the next 30 days only once you're in you
can find me in game under the name
talking Thrones and if you're fast you
can join my clan thanks again to raid
Shadow Legends for sponsoring today's
video now as I'm sure most of you
already know Game of Thrones actor Kit
Harington better known as Jon Snow has
gone to HBO with a new idea for a show
about his character as of right now we
don't know that much about this show
other than what has already been shared
by Amelia and George RR Martin if you
read George R Martin's not a Blog
website or you watch my videos then you
know he's already confirmed this
information on his blog he said yes
there is a Jon Snow show in development
our working name for this show right now
is snow there are four live-action
successor shows in development at HBO
information about three of these was
released a while ago most of you have
already heard about the nymeria show
helmed by Amanda Siegel then there's
also the show about the sea snake aka
the nine voyages with Bruno Heller and
then there's the Duncan egg show the
Hedge Knight or the night of the Seven
Kingdoms I think some of these were
officially announced and in some other
cases the news leaked out the Jon Snow
show has been in development almost as
long as the other three but for whatever
reason it was never announced and it
never leaked until now but yes this is
real this was not an official
announcement from HBO so it seems there
was another leak there's not much more I
can say right now not until HBO gives me
a green light it seems as though Amelia
has already mentioned that snow was
Kit's idea in a recent interview so
that's already out there yes it was Mr
Harrington who brought the idea to HBO I
cannot tell you the names of the writers
or showrunner since that has not been
cleared for release yet but I can say
that he brought them in as well his own
guys and they are amazing ever since
Amelia and George R Martin revealed this
information we have also found out who
else is working on this show Mr
Harrington's longtime friend and former
roommate Daniel West is also working on
this show with him not only are they
friends and former roommates but they
also already worked on a show together
at HBO now ever since this news hit the
internet everyone has been wanting to
know what this show would be about at
the end of Game of Thrones we saw Jon
Snow heading off North beyond the wall
with his direwolf ghost and his wildling
friends now that bran has the Iron
Throne what would Jon do after this as
we all know the major deadly threats are
gone Dany is dead the night king and the
white walkers are dead and drogon has
flown somewhere East most likely to Old
valyria what sort of Adventures would
Jon Snow have now well according to this
new email they are figuring out a way
they can bring the night king and the
white walkers back this is at least one
of the ideas Mr Harrington and his
writers have brought to HBO it is
interesting how HBO's new Game of
Thrones series House of the Dragon has
kept the night King story Alive by
introducing the Valyrian steel dagger
and the story of A Song of Ice and Fire
although the night king and the white
walkers really shouldn't have anything
to do with House of the Dragon since it
is set during the dance of the Dragons
HBO and its writers have made sure we
have not forgotten about the night king
and the threat that lies Beyond the Wall
I think maybe they're doing this as a
way to set up something else in the
future like maybe in this new Jon Snow
show as we all know Mr Harrington was
not happy about Arya being the one who
delivered that fatal blow to the night
King he did reveal this in an interview
while he was still filming the show now
he was friendly with his answer but we
all know this is how he really felt
kit was really fine with it I was pissed
I was pissed that it wasn't me killing
the night King I could have I would I
would have given you like I'd bet you
thousands before we read the finals I
was like yeah it's definitely me I'm not
shocked either because I know this is
how millions of fans felt as well myself
included I believe he's still very
unsatisfied without Jon Snow's story
ended and a major aspect of his story
involved the night King in his army I
mean there has to be a reason why he
wants to continue the Jon Snow show it's
no secret they had been setting this up
from the very beginning literally in the
very first episode of the show we see
Jon Snow ask about joining the Night's
Watch The Band of Brothers who guard the
realm against the White Walkers and the
night King it seemed as if Jon was
destined to face off against the night
King and as we all know he did again and
again it was Jon Snow's direwolf ghost
who discovered the whites out Beyond the
Wall it was Jon Snow in his Valyrian
steel sword who stopped the White Walker
right in front of the night King leading
to one of the greatest scenes in all of
the show in season 5 when Jon Snow and
the night King stared at each other in
the eyes everyone was sure they would
eventually face off against each other
down the road Road and they sort of did
they had another standoff in season
seven when it felt like they were still
setting up this incredible Showdown by
then it seemed inevitable that they
would fight each other in the final
battle it was Jon Snow's Journey after
all from the very beginning he was the
one who joined the Night's Watch and he
was the one who rallied the realm
together to fight this darkness when no
one else even knew or believed they
existed Arya had her own Journey which
was Vengeance for her family by
martyring everyone on her list but those
dumbasses day and Day thought it would
be too obvious if Jon fought the night
King because everyone already was
expecting it to happen if you ask me
this was one of their biggest mistakes
and this is why I do believe the source
because it would make for a far better
ending now some of you may also be
wondering how would they bring the night
king or the white walkers back we saw
Arya stab him which also made the rest
of his army fall well I wasn't given a
whole lot of information but there may
be a few ways they could get it done as
we all know the night King had some
incred incredible magical abilities Not
only was he able to reanimate an entire
Army at once but he was also able to do
this with animals as well I mean we saw
him resurrect horses Giants bears and
even a damn Dragon he could basically do
whatever the hell he wanted these
magical abilities were also very similar
to Brands and even or else now if you
remember the wildling aurel he was able
to go in and out the mind of his ego
even as he was dying after Jon Snow
stabbed him he was able to leave his own
body and live a second life inside of
his animal that's why it immediately
went after Jon Snow after he died the
man was now living a second life inside
of his Eagle well the night King has the
same ability I would even argue that
he's the greatest worg of them all since
he is able to reanimate whole armies of
men even after they're dead maybe the
night King left his body and went into
something else as Arya stabbed him maybe
the night King is now living inside of
bran maybe that's why bran all of a
sudden decided he wanted to become the
king now if you remember before the
battle bran said he couldn't become the
Lord of anything then all of a sudden he
goes to King's Landing and wants to be
the Lord of everything how insane would
it be if the night King was now inside
of bran and Jon Snow had to come back
south to kill his own brother it would
actually be very fitting because it
would be very similar to the story of
the 13th floor commander of the Night's
Watch who was also known as the Night's
King if you've ever heard one of old
man's stories then you know there was a
man known by the name of Brandon Stark
who became the Night's King during his
Reign Over the wall for 13 years he and
his Knight's Queen bound the men of the
Night's Watch to their well while also
sacrificing babies north of the wall the
only way this Night's King was stopped
was after his brother who was the Lord
of Winterfell went to the wall and
killed him I think it would be amazing
if it happened again it would certainly
explain a lot of things and make the
ending a hell of a lot better another
way they could do this is through Christ
our sons in one of the scenes all the
way back in the second season craster
revealed he had 99 sons and as we all
know he gave all of his sons to the
White Walkers and the night King well we
never actually saw all 99 of those Sons
we only saw a few dozen of them at most
who knows maybe some of them are still
out there in the lands of always winter
as of right now none of this information
can be confirmed HBO still hasn't made
an official announcement about this show
themselves although George R Martin
already has however before any of you
immediately disregard this information
let me tell you why I haven't done that
yet roughly five years ago I received
another email that looked very similar
to the one I got last night in that old
email someone sent me this photo long
before the episode ever aired on HBO as
you can see this is the scene where Jon
Snow stabs Danny like I said I had this
photo over a year before the episode
actually aired the guy who snapped this
photo actually sent it to me first
before anyone else had seen it he said
he was a fan of my video so he wanted me
to break the news even before he shared
it anywhere himself so when I made that
video saying I had the evidence of John
murdering Danny me I was flamed in the
comment section some were saying I was a
liar some were saying I made it up
myself another said the photo was fake
or from another scene basically hundreds
and thousands of fans disregarded the
photo because they couldn't believe I
had it before anyone else I want all of
you to keep that in mind before you
disregard this video I've made today the
guy who sent me this new email might be
lying but I do think it makes a lot of
sense even if he is I will have an open
mind for now and I must admit I do love
the idea so it might be some wishful
thinking on my end I obviously want it
to be real so with all of that being
said let me know what all of you think
down below I'm always open and
interested in hearing what you have to
say as always I want to thank all of you
for watching this video I hope all of
you have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye